welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we are hosting
webinars every Tuesday my name is Weston
Hutchins I'm a product manager on G K
and my name is Ennis envieth I'm a
product manager in geek areas while
focusing networking and today we're
talking about three reasons why you
should run your enterprise workloads on
google kubernetes engine so you can ask
questions at any time on the platform
and we have Googlers on standby to
answer them with that let's get started
so it's no secret that containers are
generating more and more buzz every day
and it's pretty much a requirement for
enterprises today to have containers as
part of their long term IT roadmap and
strategy Gartner estimates that by 2020
50% of global organizations will be
running containerized workloads in
production across a wide variety of
industries including finding its media
manufacturing and more so as part of any
strong container management platform you
need to make sure that kubernetes is in
the conversation for orchestrating those
workloads as you start to move from
virtual machines over to a container
based infrastructure now for those that
aren't familiar with kubernetes this
isn't going to be a deep dive or
anything like that but I did want to at
least talk a little bit about some of
the benefits that kubernetes gives you
out of the box kubernetes is a an open
portable container centric management
platform and a lot of what kubernetes
does is is build a platform to help you
extend and manage your applications that
are containerized on on the underlying
infrastructure that you have for me
kubernetes is really two main key
components the first one is that it's an
infrastructure abstraction layer when
you go and create a kubernetes cluster
kubernetes hides a lot of the underlying
infrastructure things like networking
storage compute you don't really have to
think about the the nuances of that from
platform to platform kubernetes gives
you a standardized infrastructure layer
to program or applications against the
second piece is that it's a descent of
declarative api's for managing
applications
centric workloads so as you start to
roll out applications there are a number
of things that you need to handle
including things like making your
application available health checking
making sure that your load balancing
between different services in your
cluster and kubernetes one of the nice
things about kubernetes is that has
built-in primitives to handle a lot of
those application management features
for you automatically kubernetes can be
a little complex especially when you're
getting started but if you think about
what it normally takes to run a
production grade application there's a
ton of things that kubernetes gives you
out of the box just to make your life a
lot simpler
so just to cherry pick a few of these
looking at scheduling so across the
fleet of of instances that I have set up
around the world how do I decide where
to take containers and pods and schedule
those across the different nodes how do
I ensure that my applications are always
up-to-date and healthy even though I
know that failures can occur kubernetes
allows you to go and restart those pods
and restart those applications when
things don't go quite right
we handle things like load balancing and
scaling kubernetes has built-in
primitives for making sure that you're
making sure that your cluster is always
been able to handle the load that hits
it on peak hours and then scale back
down during off-peak hours to save you
money when you're running your cluster
at scale it has built-in primitives for
storage volumes that work across a
number of different cloud providers and
gives you a nice portable abstraction
layer to say I want disk storage and
have that work well across GCP and AWS
and even on Prem systems and then it
includes a lot of built-in tools and
services on top of everything that
kubernetes gives you out of the box so
things like logging and monitoring
there's a ton of extensions and
pluggable frameworks for making your
cluster observable and making your apps
observable within those clusters so
while kubernetes can feel a bit daunting
i think like as people start to get
ramped up with the platform around
kubernetes you'll see that a lot of
these features that kubernetes gives you
means that you don't have to think about
these yourself when you're rolling out
your containers so what we've actually
seen is like an increase in usage in
kübra
quite substantially the rapid adoption
has been dramatic you know I I went to
cube con here in Seattle just a couple
of years ago and there's been a 10x
increase from the latest cube con that
just was hosted in Copenhagen and recent
surveys suggest that over fifty four
percent of Fortune 100 companies are
using kubernetes in production today so
there's really no better time to get
started experimenting with the
containers and using kubernetes as your
orchestration platform of choice but by
far the easiest way to get started with
kubernetes is to use Google's fully
managed kubernetes solution kubernetes
engine some of the biggest benefits to
using kubernetes engine is that you can
start your cluster with the single click
and once you have that cluster
provisioned you can view all of the
workloads in the Google Cloud console
from this beautiful UI screen so you can
see things like what what applications
are running across my cluster what
services are there how do I set up
discovery a service discovery and load
balancing across the different services
within the cluster and even start to
tweak things like configuration of
secrets and config maps that are in your
cluster as well all from the Google
cloud platform console but by far the
best part about gke and the one that we
hear repeatedly from customers is that
Google manages the cluster for you so
you don't have to manage it yourself
there are a lot of day to operations
that are just challenging things like
making sure that xcd is scaled making
sure that itit is backed up having high
availability components as part of your
control plan that can resist outages
there's a lot of domain knowledge that
comes in managing a kubernetes cluster
and Google couldn't kubernetes engine
handles a lot of that hard work for you
so in this webinar
you know we're gonna primarily be
focusing on a few of the attributes and
considerations that you need to think
about when you're starting to move from
a VM world over to something built on
containers and kubernetes there are a
lot of fundamental questions that you
need to start thinking through such as
how does kubernetes fit into the
operational model that I already have I
have people that are used to doing
approval flows and provisioning machines
can kubernetes fit into that well or fit
into that system very well there's a
bunch of other
things that you need to start thinking
about like scalability availability
security and for this webinar in
particular we're just going to be
focusing on three reasons why you should
start thinking about communities and
especially start thinking about using
google kubernetes engine so the three
key areas we're going to be looking at
our reliability availability and how
kubernetes and gke fits into your
company's operational model so on
reliability google kubernetes images are
already trusted by many enterprises
today and the reason is that we've been
doing containers at scale for more than
a decade right now internally kubernetes
or containers have been used as Borg or
internal our internal container
orchestration system all the way since
2006 and then we started to see
containers really pick up mine share in
the developer community
so docker was announced in 2013 and
started to get a lot of traction and
this is when we started thinking about
how we could help accelerate the
container based application environment
like offering primitives that helped you
run applications built on containers and
this is really where we took the lessons
we've learned from our internal system
board and started applying it towards
kubernetes and in around 2015 is when
the firt 1.0 GA of kubernetes launched
and shortly after that we launched the
the general availability of our fully
managed offering kubernetes engine and
so the key here the key message here is
that we've not only been doing
containers for a long time we've been
doing kubernetes for a long time so ever
since kubernetes hit GA we've had a
fully managed solution on top of
Google's cloud platform and we've
learned a ton by managing and operating
this over the over that period so
there's a ton of domain knowledge that
our SRE team has and our dev has about
running what it takes to run kubernetes
at scale some of the nice features that
GK gives you out of the box in terms of
reliability is just making sure that
your cluster is you can trust Google to
run your cluster for you so we do a lot
of things where we take the control
plane in the in the complexities of
running that and hand that over to our
SRA team and a lot of the automation
we've built to run kubernetes here on
here
GCP so some of the features we give you
our managed control plane where you can
turn on features like auto repair and
auto upgrades which I'll talk about in a
minute we do a ton of testing on
kubernetes versions and node operating
systems to ensure compatibility and we
have a long list of configuration
matrices that were always testing to
make sure that we're rolling out new
versions of kubernetes that will not
break your your existing cluster one of
the really key features of using
something like gke
is the deep integration that we have
with the other line Google cloud
platform so we have an amazing is system
that allows you to boot our cluster
faster than any of the other cloud
providers we have deep integration with
our networking and at VP C stack which
as we'll be talking about shortly and
then you can get features like CI CD
container builder registry logging and
monitoring to alene V and stackdriver to
just give you that overall confidence
and operational ability to consistently
deploy applications to your cluster and
then monitor those production apps as
they're as they're out there in your and
Nero GK cluster but by far and I
mentioned this before the most important
thing is that we have a set of s erease
that are always monitoring your cluster
and making changes some of the actions
that they perform are keeping sed backed
up and recovered in case of a disaster
recovery monitoring for global outages
and making sure that we can respond to
those quickly and then alerting you when
there are problems in the cluster that
you may be hitting like scalability
limits of kubernetes such as too many
namespaces or too many services that
you've created and all of this is comes
out-of-the-box just by using GK's
platform so now i want to talk about
availability and we recently launched a
number of new features around
availability these features are regional
clusters node out of repair and regional
persistent disks which just went to beta
the first feature that I want to cover
is regional clusters so we announced the
GA of this last week regional clusters
is an improvement on the zonal clusters
that we were offering for gke and what
it does is it spreads your control plane
across three zones in a region and it
also spreads your nodes across three
zones in a region to give your
increased availability as well all of
this communication happens through a
tolerant a highly tolerant load balancer
system so that even if one of these were
to go down you can always shift traffic
over to a new zone so the biggest
benefits with having this high
availability multi master set up is that
you get an increased SLO an increased
uptime as part of gke where you get
three and a half 9s but by far the
feature that we hear most of the
customers really wanted was this ability
to do zero downtime control plane
upgrades so as as you start as we start
rolling out new versions of kubernetes
we will actually do a one by one upgrade
of your zonal are sort of your regional
control plan an upgrade each zone at a
time so that your control plane is
always having the ability to serve
traffic for your for your applications
as a quick aside I do want to talk a
little bit about upgrade strategies and
these are just general best practice
tips when you're thinking about how do i
keep my app updated and highly available
during an upgrade so I think one of the
first tips is using something like
regional clusters to make sure you have
zero downtime but let's cover a few
other general best practices here so
just a brief primer on the architecture
the way google kubernetes engine is set
up is that you have a control plane
which is a set of master nodes that are
managed by google and then you have your
nodes which are controlled by you in
your own project that run your workloads
and from the control point aspect Google
manages the upgrades for you so we will
automatically upgrade the control plane
as new versions of kubernetes are
available now the thing to note is that
we don't always upgrade every cluster to
the latest version of kubernetes we
typically pick a stable version that's
usually one or two releases behind
however you as the customer always have
the option of trying the latest and
greatest by clicking the upgrade
available link inside the Google Cloud
console or running it from a g-cloud
command and the most important piece
about this is you have control over when
you want to upgrade to the newest
versions but we will always but make
sure that security patches and other
fixes are performed on your cluster for
you automatically and as I mentioned
before if you really want to have
increased availability
you zero downtime during upgrade as its
as it's a much better model for
maintaining the uptime of your cluster
so past the control plane you need to
think about how you're going to keep
your nodes upgraded to make sure
specifically that they're available
while you're serving traffic so there's
a couple features that I wanted to
mention first off you can choose to turn
on auto upgrade for your cluster and
this is particularly what I recommend
for for customers that want to make sure
that their custom that their cluster is
always kept up-to-date with the latest
security patches or if you want more
control you can choose to turn off the
feature and manually upgrade your
cluster as newer versions are supported
one feature that you can use to control
win upgrades happen is called
maintenance windows and this feature
allows you to set a schedule and a
four-hour window of which you say
upgrades are allowed to happen during
this particular time period and that
just gives you a little more confidence
that your cluster will always be able to
serve peak traffic but then we can keep
things upgraded when when less load is
hitting the cluster but in terms of
upgrade strategy there's two common
patterns that I've seen about keeping
nodes up-to-date the first is just what
GK gives you out of the box which is a
rolling update if you go and click the
button in the bottom right hand corner
of showing in the bottom right hand
corner here our node upgrades are
available and I'll walk you through a
wizard where we will upgrade your
cluster one node at a time and a rolling
upgrade fashion this is nice just
because it's simple and easy but it does
have one big downside in that you need
to make sure that your cluster can
operate with one reduced node during
that upgrade process so we will
constantly we will constantly be taking
a note down draining it and then adding
it back with a newer version of
kubernetes one way to handle this is
just to provision an extra capacity
during your update process and we hope
to make this more automatic and easier
in the future the second the second
common strategy that I see is migration
with node pools so one of the nice
things about node pools is that it
allows you to create a group of nodes on
a newer version of kubernetes and do a
form of traffic shifting over to that
new version so what you can do is create
a second node pool as part of the same
cluster on a newer version and then one
by one use
cube got old to go and drain the nodes
and then court on the nodes which will
then start to reschedule pods on the
newer version of kubernetes and this
allows you a little bit more control
over the upgrade process and also gives
you the ability to rollback in case
things start going wrong so this is a
really nice process that you can use in
order to go and upgrade your clusters to
the newest versions one other feature
that we just announced ga4 is auto
repair now your kubernetes cluster nodes
can go down for a number of reasons
there can be kernel bugs they can be
unreachable you can have out of memory
or out of storage exceptions and what
auto repair does is it constantly is
monitoring and health checking your
nodes and if it detects a problem such
as a node not responding it will go and
Rhys pin up those nodes and keep that
cluster up-to-date and this is what we
found from customers that this is
usually a feature that they love to just
have one in the background and
constantly keeping those clusters up as
problems are introduced the other new
feature that we just announced is a
regional persistent disk support for
kubernetes engine now one of the nice
things about regional persistent disks
is that typically doing distributed
storage replication is really
challenging and what regional persistent
volumes give you the ability to do is
automatically replicate between two
zones in a region so rather than having
to think about how do i how do i shard
my applications such that it's
automatically replicating across
different zones you can just replicate
at the storage layer and have google
handle all of that for you automatically
so this is a huge time-saver and
complexity reducer for those that want
to have the increased availability with
having storage replicated across
multiple zones in a region and we've
really seen a lot of customers come to
depend and rely on the high uptime and
availability of gke
especially around events like Black
Friday where we can see a massive
increase in traffic we have gone through
this many many years and are able to
scale up our clusters in order to meet
customer demand and without oven
delivery - it is thanks so much
where'sa I want to swirl then to focus
on the operational model for your
kubernetes deployment and the reason why
I'll be focusing on the networking the
reason why this is important is because
enterprises run the kubernetes
deployment as part of their the rest of
the of the deployments and it we need to
make sure that everything that we build
in terms of the models to fit into the B
PC and to a scale the current
deployments they also work for the
kubernetes deployment so I'm going to be
focusing on a couple of very important
foundational concepts that we have
released and that are going to allow us
to really provide you with their tools
and the models that you'll need for your
deployment so I want to back up a little
bit and talk about Google BBC Network
the reason why this is significant is
because it really provides very
significant advantages over some other
networking models so we have been
already work as as Google we have
significant expertise on building global
networks and we have done so for our
business areas as we build our public
cloud model we really liberate on that
global networking model exposing through
the BBC the possibility for you as a
user to build your global piece of
Google network for your enterprises the
reason why that is significant is
because it significantly reduce the
amount of operational burden that you
will have on having to stitch regional
connectivity domains and having that
offer to you by default it will as well
mitigate the fact that you need to
connect separately from your data
centers if you have open systems through
separate connections like Google cloud
network will offer you a single entry
point for all your deployments globally
and as well it allows you a centralized
model for having your security and
policy construct now when we are
applying that to to kubernetes
we are really making sure that
everything that we have built for any
type of deployments it works natively on
on kubernetes so with that I'm going to
introduce the first key construct that
you will need for your kubernetes
deployments it is what we call natively
Picea
kubernetes engine clusters we salius IP
the reason why this is significant is
because when we are working with
container deployments really the
granularity at which we are providing
networking functions is not any more at
the granularity of a VM instance you
need to provide the networking functions
at the granularity of eyepiece with
represent spots and the pasok onions
shown represent services that get
exposed to the user now when we are
managing the networking functions for
those ports and services things like IP
allocation they are done through the
native music UK clusters they're done
natively in as part of our DCP model you
can allocate as part of your BP C sub
net primary range that it serves us the
IP allocation rains from which you are
allocating IP for pots then you can have
a secondary range that you use for
allocating your services eyepiece you
can keep those two separated but the
nice thing is that by doing the
allocation as part of your V PC model
you don't need to have two separate IP
allocation systems one for your pots on
your service as part of your DK
deployments another for your BM such
they underline infrastructure
additionally the ability to program
directly these pots as part of our V PC
infrastructure did make sure that we are
addressing natively those pots and all
services program in our networking stack
that allows us to scale better it
provides us well advantages like with
security because we are able to
understand which spots are allocated
which PM instances and therefore we're
allowed to implicitly apply anticipate
making sure that the eyepiece from the
pods are really the ones that are being
configured by you as a user and in
general it really gives us the
foundational block to provide every
single networking service whether we're
talking about load balancing functions
whether we're talking about routing
exposing those routes to the internet
everything as part of the e ke clusters
ports and services are treated as the
same as we will do with our VM instance
deployments let's now talk about the
operational needs for your for your
kubernetes engine so we have seen the
following paradigm for when deploy in
kubernetes engine clusters on one side
there is usefully a network and security
administration that needs to have some
control if only to understand what are
the rules of connectivity what are
firewalls and what are the security
policies through which the deployments
having govern as part of those
deployments so there is a need for
having a centralized view and a
centralized at mean for certain very
sensitive security policies and routing
policies on the other hand you have the
paradigm in which the demo they live up
steams they need to be agile enough so
that they have the autonomy to be able
to deploy and to operate their
applications without having to have a
very tight dependency on the
infrastructure and those administrative
policies so they we see requirements so
for those DevOps to have separate
billing separate quotas separate iam
control so they can be able to operate
the wraps without stepping into each
other fit the last is that when you're
deploying your niihka apps you want to
make sure that they are able to
communicate privately the reason why
this is important is because when you're
having a micro service
set of environment and you'd break in
your mana rate it's very important that
those apps are they still able to
communicate without having to be exposed
to the internet and there's this
requirements all very important when you
have CI CD environments in which you
want to promote certain apps you know
from deployment to test to stake in an
app production so with that I want to
back up a little bit because the way
these problems have been resolved has
been some optimal and that is where I
Google cloud is stepping up to provide a
solution that really meets those
requirements with a solution that is
suitable for your operational needs so
why those deployments have been
suboptimal so for example one very
traditional way of deploying the key
clusters it will be to have it in your
in your own account and your own project
so that you you can have your your
control for billing for quota for
identity and access management policies
restricted to that cluster so that you
have the separations its cluster and
it's a set of developers then they're
going to be separating separated by this
type of controls and then they
communicate through a PPC control but if
you are really deploying an application
a an application B as part of the same
cluster you are really loosing they
control on some of those policies so you
get the communication through the BBC
Network like in this like in this
picture but then you are losing the
ability for those developers to have
their own quota to have their own
building the other option is now you
separate them fully you have application
a which is really restricted to a
cluster to a single account then you
have application B which is restricted
to another cluster to another account
but now the VP sees that you really
connect those clusters to which provide
you your virtual connectivity
domaine are separated you're not really
able to communicate easily those
applications and then you create silos
so you are trading of the communication
that you had in the previous picture
with the able to control their each of
the applications that you can in this
picture in all of them you have the
optimal setup for being able to separate
policies and control for those clusters
but having private connectivity without
creating silos that is where the model
for Shelby PC comes in place and if you
see it at the deployment that we have
here what it allows you is to really
have your clusters deployed separately
in different projects that will have
separate billing accounts for those
applications separate quota separate
identity and administration and an
identity management those policies are
they still completely separated for
application a and application B but
there is still a single PC network that
is able to connect the both applications
and not only is able to connect probably
both applications but it's also able to
provide a common space in which there
can be a set of route a set of firewalls
that are globally administer biosecurity
networking admin that can then gain
control on how these applications are
are communicating now it provides you a
single place in which you can understand
what are the communication rules and
what are the security policies for those
applications without having these de
Bob's having to care about that what
that connectivity of what those rules
are so to recap when you are deploying
your applications as part of your DKE
deployment it is very important that
your developer will be able to
autonomously develop and be able to
operate test and deploy and operate
their
vacations without a step in it on each
other toes now this the developers are
really good at doing their job they're
really good at having their applications
develop testing them making sure that
they perform they are not the shoe not
beat responsible of having to set up the
networking the underlying networking
connectivity to connect with others they
should not have to be responsible of how
do I now make my connectivity available
to this other application that I need to
communicate with that is what the share
PPC comes in place it gives us security
and networking at me not only a place to
control that is very similar to the
traditional enterprise models but it
gives you a way to enable your
developers for really setting up for
them those communication and those
security policy rules so that it will
make their life really easy for them and
just to recap we have seen tremendous
traction on adopting this enterprise
models we've got a lot of feedback for
large enterprises in which the Shelby PC
model is really the choice for their
large enterprise deployment started to
achieve the to be able to achieve an
operational model that doesn't come up
with the trade-offs that we have seen in
the past and as well we have seen the
customers really acknowledging the fact
that we are providing the networking
capabilities when it comes to
performance and a scale to kubernetes
deployments natively the same way that
we are doing for the rest of the billion
deployments or any other type of
deployments on our platform so we really
are going to a model in which kubernetes
and the container deployments are
first-class citizens for everything on
networking which will allow our
customers to get advantage day one for
from the performance the global scale
the global reach ability that Google
Network provides with that
really wrapping up here stay tuned for
life Q&A because we are going to be back
in less than a minute thank you
you
all right we're back and we'll take some
questions that we had during the session
so the first question is what are the
differences between multi zone and
regional clusters so before we launched
regional clusters we had this concept
called multi zone clusters and what it
what it allowed you to do was take a
sonal control plan that ran in a single
zone and then create node pools in
different zones so if you had a cluster
that you wanted to create in US central
1a you could then add a node pool that
was in US central 1b or 1c or wherever
you want it to go and create those with
regional clusters we give you that
functionality automatically out of the
box so when you go and create a cluster
it automatically spreads your nodes
across the different zones for you the
other major difference is that we
replicate the control plan so we spread
the masters across three different zones
in a region and we replicate @cd between
those so multi zone was kind of the old
way of doing it for zonal clusters and
it's still really good for test clusters
or development clusters where you just
want to spin it up and add some more
capacity to try out service discovery
across different zones but regional
clusters is really what you want to be
using for the increased availability and
zero downtime then you get for running
production-grade applications all right
so the next question is do I have to
spread my notes across three zones in a
region and I think this is probably
talking about regional clusters I
mentioned that we automatically create
node pools and three zones in a
particular region but I do want to point
out that that's not a requirement so you
can control both where the nodes are
created and also how many nodes in each
of those zones are created so for
example by passing in the flag there's a
node locations flag that you can use to
actually create a regional cluster that
is actually in a single zone so you
might want to do this in order to save
egress across between different zones if
you're not really sure about how your
cluster or services are communicating
with one another or you just want to
keep everything local to a zone but you
want to have the additional availability
of a regional control plan so it's
really easy to mix and match those
you just by specifying the new locations
flag and then if you want to you can
even specify the number of nodes flag
which allows you to say whether or not
you want one two three n number of nodes
created in each particular zone all
right so I'll take the next question
when should I use share BBC for my ek
deployment so typically you want to use
share BBC as long as you have
separations administrative separations
that you want to provide autonomy and
that could be when you have let's say a
department a department B that are
running different applications or even
to the granularity of a specific
application developer so you want to
have application a an application via
separating their own projects you can
actually partition your deployments to
the granularity that it suits you the
sharpest is going to allow you to
communicate really that are those
applications that you are separating for
administrative reason so we see
different use cases from having like two
or three you know big department so
maybe an environment studies test stay
in production that are separated and
communicated through a share BBC or we
see to the granularity of different
developers that are managing the
different applications being separated
and connected through a share BBC so
every time that you want to provide
network communication that is private
that is provided to your developers as a
service that they have available to them
that's what they need to connect and you
want to keep them isolated in the sense
of administratively for having their own
billing quota and a.m. so that they are
owners of their own resources that's
where your show BBC models come in place
I'll do it the next question as well if
we expose services inside BBC can they
yes in stay internal to the enterprise
absolutely so
this is actually one of the most
prevalent models in enterprise
deployment there is the capability to
have your through the configuration of
the alias IP that we just talked about
you configure your infrastructure BMS
you configure your ports and your
services as private type is configured
as part of the same BBC subnet and then
you decide which services are going to
be exposed now the fact that you're
exposing those services it totally
doesn't need to mean that you are
exposing them publicly you can expose
them within your BBC and because you now
have a share BBC really you have a model
in which those services communicate
privately to your enterprise across your
different cluster deployments and the
last one why our native BBC clusters
more secure one of the big things we're
enabling with native BBC clusters is the
fact that we as networking stock we
understand where the ports and where
each of the services are really located
as part of our our infrastructure so
what it means is that we are able to
understand that applications are hosted
on a specific on a specific notes on a
specific host of our infrastructure in
doing so we are then able to apply
security checks like IP spoofing like
when we're actually allowing traffic to
a specific node we are allowing only
traffic for applications that having
configure as part of that node so if I
have let's say put one with IP 10.0.0.0
'[ __ ] destiny to that node is destiny to
a to a PUD IP that is hosted there and
if not I'm not going to allow that
traffic to come in so we're really
natively ensure that the traffic is
Leggett when they're communicating
throughout infrastructure because we
understand where applications are hosted
if you have any other questions will be
online afterwards to help answer them
you can use the platform typing your
questions and we'll jump on with any
other thing that you have now stay tuned
for the next session coming live it from
Sunnyvale why api's are products not
one-off projects thank you very much